[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
janna paradies herzlich willkommen zu
zehn minuten nachrichten und das in
unsere großen themen heute
scholz und der steuerskandal der
bundeskanzler muss einem
untersuchungsausschuss erneut fragen zur
comex affäre beantworten
manöver in australien 12.000 kilometer
entfernt von deutschland ist die
bundeswehr mit eurofightern im einsatz
und e-scooter im straßenverkehr bei
unfällen sollen fahrer leichter haftbar
gemacht werden können
da war nichts mit diesem satz hat
kanzler scholz heute erneut die vorwürfe
zurückgewiesen er habe als hamburger
bürgermeister einfluss genommen auf das
steuerverfahren der warburg-bank die
hamburger bank hatte steuern hinterzogen
der hamburger fiskus verzichtete
zunächst aber darauf diese million durch
sogenannte comics geschäfte von der bank
zurück zu fordern warum das soll der
untersuchungsausschuss klären vor denen
der kanzler heute geladen war ralf
zimmermann von sie fand es ist sein
alter wirkungsort der olaf scholz nicht
los lässt in seinem neuen amt als
kanzler aufgeräumt wirkt er heute trotz
mancher auch neue fragen in den letzten
tagen zum beispiel ob es löschungen von
e-mails gab womöglich selbst noch im
kanzleramt in den letzten monaten doch
weder dazu noch zu den treffen mit den
bankern im jahr 2016 und 17 konnte oder
wollte scholz neues beitragen gebe zu
ich hatte mich darauf eingerichtet dass
es viel länger dauert aber die tatsache
dass es dann schnell und zügig war
spricht vielleicht auch für die tatsache
dass alles nun mittlerweile auf dem
tisch liegt und man auch die klare
schlussfolgerung ziehen kann da war
nichts es hat keine einflussnahme
gegeben doch die oppositionsparteien
lassen nicht locker mit ihrem verdacht
dass scholz und sein damaliger
finanzsenator und nachfolger als
bürgermeister peter tschentscher dafür
sorgten dass die hamburger finanzämter
auf eine steuerrückzahlung von 47
millionen euro von warburg verzichteten
es ist für uns deswegen auch schlecht
weil wir natürlich aufklärung machen
wollen und jemand der sich an nichts
erinnern kann wie sollen wir da
aufklären warum es gewisse probleme der
hamburgischen verweist finanzverwaltung
gegeben hat es spricht sehr viel dafür
dass wir olaf scholz auch in den
finanzausschuss des deutschen
bundestages einladen werden hamburg war
das einzige bundesland das
steuerbetrügern hier einen erlass
gewähren wollte und das unter der
politischen verantwortung eines
regierungschefs olaf scholz erinnert
wurde heute auch noch einmal an die
erinnerungslücken des kanzlers schon bei
seiner ersten vernehmung vor gut einem
jahr die bürgerinitiative finanz wände
beispielsweise hält den comic skandal
auch noch für längst nicht aufgeklärt
und alle banerjee hat die sitzung des
ausschusses für uns verfolgt und an
welchen eindruck hat in der kanzlei bei
der befragung gemacht
also olaf scholz ist hier heute sehr
selbstbewusst aufgetreten und das konnte
auch denn diese befragung hat ihn nicht
wirklich in bedrängnis gebracht er hat
die ganze veranstaltung geöffnet mit
einer gut 20-minütigen erklärungen der
viele entlastende details aus
medienberichterstattung für sich ins
feld geführt hat und danach haben sich
die mitglieder des ausschusses
ungefähr drei stunden bemüht trotzdem
widersprüche aufzuzeigen und seine
glaubwürdigkeit in frage zu stellen vor
allem ging es um die vielen vielen
erinnerungslücken die ihr hier gezeigt
hat über 30 fragen wurden gestellt viele
davon hat er beantwortet mit daran kann
ich mich nicht erinnern oder das weiß
ich nicht und damit ist der ausschuss
natürlich nicht besonders weit gekommen
der linken obmann hat hier zum schluss
gesagt wir haben keinen beleg dass es
wohl auch das problem gewesen denn ohne
beleg lässt sich die einfluss einer
einflussnahme die ihm dort vorgeworfen
wird eben nicht nicht stichfest machen
und dabei bleibt es bei der frage was
hat er gewusst dazu hat er heute nichts
neues beigetragen eine dritte befragung
so hieß es heute hier nach der nach der
sitzung scheint nicht ausgeschlossen zu
sein die aufklärung geht also weiter
dankeschön manager
der comic skandal ist auch thema bei zdf
heute live ab 19.30 in der zdf- heute-
app und auf youtube und alle details
gibt es auch nochmal online zum
nachlesen
das russische gas unternehmen gazprom
kündigt eine weitere unterbrechung
seiner lieferungen an wegen
wartungsarbeiten werde ende des monats
drei tage lang ein glas in deutschland
ankommen sollten keine technischen
probleme auftauchen würde die nordstream
1 leitung anschließend wieder
hochgefahren seit wochen kommen ohnehin
nur 20 prozent der üblichen
gaslieferungen aus russland in
deutschland an offiziell aus technischen
gründen
der französische und russische präsident
waren sich in ihrem telefonat heute
einig die internationale
atomenergieagentur muss zutritt erhalten
zur anlage des atomkraftwerks in
fukushima seit tagen machen sich die
russische und die ukrainische führung
gegenseitig für den beschuss
verantwortlich
unterdessen hat un generalsekretär gut
tennis sein besuch in der ukraine
fortgesetzt
heute in odessa um zu schauen wie das
getreide abkommen zwischen kiew und
moskau umgesetzt wird inzwischen seien
über 600.000 tonnen getreide auf dem weg
es sei noch viel zu tun so gut herrisch
die entwicklungsländer bräuchten massive
hilfen
nach australien die deutsche luftwaffe
nimmt dort erstmals an militärmanövern
teil mehrere eurofighter und
transportflugzeuge mussten dafür verlegt
werden von deutschland ging es über abu
dhabi und singapur nach down under so
weit weg wie noch nie das ziel darwin im
norden australiens an der militärübung
beteiligen sich insgesamt 17 nationen
mit rund
2.500 soldatinnen und soldaten
normen odenthal hat die luftwaffe
begleitet
der weg nach australien ist weit mehr
als 12.000 kilometer die luftwaffe
schafft mit ihren eurofightern in gut 20
stunden schneller als gedacht mit kurzen
zwischenstopps und dutzenden auf tankern
in der luft maßarbeit den tankstutzen
den korb zu platzieren jedes mal ein
risiko
routine hilft kann aber auch gefährlich
werden der abstand zwischen jet und
tanker bedenken tanken selbst und circa
15 bis 20 meter also dass bei
geschwindigkeiten von fast 900 km h das
braucht schon volle konzentration
das manöver am anderen ende der welt ist
für die luftwaffe eine große sache nie
zuvor haben deutsche flieger in dieser
ferne operiert das ziel beweisen dass
man es kann einsatzfähigkeit wo
erforderlich wir müssen und das zeigt ja
die jetzige politische situation in
europa sehr deutlich schnell reagieren
können wenn wir dann den auftrag kriegen
dann müssen wir im besten fall innerhalb
eines tages in einem gebiet sein wo
einfach politische spannungen oder
vielleicht krisen krieg herrscht und der
indopazifik ist ein brennpunkt zwischen
west und ost usa und china mit
eskalationsgefahr in teilen deutschlands
interesse in der region stabilität ohne
in einen konflikt gezogen zu werden jede
provokation vermeiden denn chinas
argwohn ist groß die luftwaffe fliegt
hier nur auf internationalen
luftstrassen wir sind völlig unbewaffnet
und ich sehe in keinster weise dass wir
irgendeinen signal gegen jemanden
sondern wir senden ein signal für die
partner die wir in dieser region haben
die luftwaffe wagt sich ungewohnt weit
vor mit dieser mission und das in jeder
hinsicht
nach dem massenhaften fischsterben inder
oder gibt es jetzt erstmal in warnung
zumindest für den deutschen teil des
stettiner haffs hier sind wasserproben
laut landesregierung in mecklenburg
vorpommern unauffällig aus der oder
wurden bisher mehr als 100 tonnen tote
fische gesammelt nach angaben der
behörden sei der flusspegel kurz vor
bekanntwerden der katastrophe um fast 6
30 zentimeter angestiegen ein weiteres
indiz dafür dass wohl gezielt abwasser
oder chemikalien eingeleitet wurden
satellitenbilder sollen deshalb jetzt
ausgewertet werden
mehr als 5000 unfälle mit eastern wurden
im vergangenen jahr registriert die
meisten mit verletzten tendenz stark
steigend aber wer schuld hat ist oft
schwer zu klären
expertinnen des verkehrsgerichtstages in
goslar empfehlen deshalb die
haftungsregeln für die scooter zu
verschärfen das doch schneider die einen
lieben sie die anderen hassen sie
escooter wendig und kompakt sind die
elektro kleinstfahrzeuge stehen an fast
jeder straßenecke
doch wenn unfälle mit eastern passieren
wird es rechtlich oft schwierig den die
unterliegen nicht der sogenannten
gefährdungshaftung die autos weil sie
mit weniger als 20 km h unterwegs sind
heißt konkret bei unfällen muss die
schuld des guter fahrers nachgewiesen
werden um schadenersatz zu erhalten
gelingt dieser nachweis nicht geht man
leer aus
scooter weisen eine erhebliche
gefährlichkeit im straßenverkehr auf und
deswegen ist der ausschluss der
gefährdungshaftung dort nicht
gerechtfertigt das muss sich ändern
fordert jetzt der verkehrsgerichtstag in
goslar der gesetzgeber muss eigentlich
im grunde genommen e scooter genauso
behandeln wie autos oder wie
kraftfahrzeuge denn dort ist völlig klar
wenn es zu einem unfall kommt dann
haftet auch der kraftfahrzeug halter
auch bei langsamen landmaschinen die
bauartbedingt nicht schneller als 20
km/h fahren müsse die gefährdungshaftung
greifen meinen experten in den früheren
zeiten hat man gesagt die sind nicht
schnell die langsam fahrenden
landmaschinen sind nicht schneller als
pferde vor werke deswegen nicht
gefährlich bei den heutigen
verkehrsverhältnissen erscheint mir das
nicht mehr gerechtfertigt nun ist der
gesetzgeber gefordert die vorschläge aus
goslar umzusetzen das haftungsrecht
modernen verkehr es hat dringend ein
update nötig
erst die wochenlange trockenheit und
jetzt das in teilen bayerns und baden
württembergs geht derzeit dauerregen
nieder besonders extremes wetter droht
am alpenrand es sind ausläufer der
unwetter die gestern bereits über
österreich hinweg gezogen waren dort
kamen fünf menschen ums leben
zehntausende haushalte waren
zwischenzeitlich ohne strom der verkehr
im süden des landes lahmgelegt
sie war eine gefeierte wandlungsfähige
schauspielerin und sängerin und wurde
bekannt auch durch ihre beziehung mit
liedermacher wolf biermann
eva-maria haben jetzt ist sie im alter
von 87 jahren gestorben
kurz nach ihrem theaterdebüt in den 1950
er jahren wurde sie in der ddr auch zum
kinostar und spielte in etwa 50 filmen
mit als sie 1976 gegen die ausbürgerung
ihres lebensgefährten wolf biermann
protestierte belegte man sie mit
berufsverbot sie und ihre tochter nina
hagen ging daraufhin in die
bundesrepublik
der deutsche wetterdienst warnt vor
ergiebigen dauerregen in teilen von
bayern und baden württemberg mehr
erfahren sie gleich von christa oben um
22.40 begrüßt sie anne gellinek zum
heute schon mal wir wünschen ihnen
gleich viel spaß mit dem european
championships
[Musik]
guten abend unwetterartiger dauerregen
fällt heute nacht und zwar vom bodensee
und dem alpenrand bis zum bayerischen
wald können bis morgen früh teils 140
liter pro quadratmeter regen
zusammenkommen das sorgt für
überflutungen und für erdrutsche achten
sie hier also in jedem fall auf das
wetter einige schauer und gewitter gibt
es in der nacht noch im osten dann haben
wir einen trockenen streifen vom
schwarzwald bis an die küste von westen
her kommen aber wieder neue schauer und
gewitter nach die schwenken dann so
langsam im tagesverlauf über die mitte
des landes im osten ohnehin noch etwas
schauer und einige gewitter vor allem
eben anfangs noch richtung süden dieser
gewittrige dauerregen von westen her
tritt dann eine wetterberuhigung ein das
ganze weil temperaturen zwischen 18 und
27 grad in den nächsten tagen beruhigt
sich das wetter wir haben zwar noch
einige schauer und gewitter aber
insgesamt wird es trocken bei einem
gleichbleibenden temperaturen niveau
zwischen 21 und 30 grad